Let's go next to our caller from the 8 5 8
area code, who's calling today from 8 5 8.
Yes, I mean, yes, it is.
Hi, it's Matthew from Southern California.
Hey, Matthew, it's a.
Oh, well, I mean, I had a main question, but
I wanted to make a quick comment.
I don't know if you know L.A. and San Diego.
I don't know if they're the exact same, ORDINATE
says, but they were closing all the beaches
and all of the trails because so many people
were looking for outdoor activity to keep
their minds off of everything.
Yeah, they just couldn't keep their distance.
I didn't know that my brother lives in Southern
California.
And obviously, he told me about the stay home
order that started and all of that.
But I did.
I knew a lot of people were going to trails.
I didn't know that they were starting to be
closed down.
That that's it's unfortunate because one of
the things that seems like a good idea is
if you keep your distance outside, you know,
get the vitamin D, get the exercise, etc.
But if people are just crowding, it defeats
the purpose.
Oh, definitely.
So it's unfortunate, but seems it seems necessary.
Yeah.
My main question was about the talk.
I hear a little less of it now, but when there
was talk about back during some of the most
recent primaries, there was actually talk
about the general election as well.
And it was about, you know, how do we deal
with this virus while having voting access
or is it possible that Trump would try to
delay the election or something?
And I'm thinking maybe we should be reframing
it to voter access, you know, vote by mail
or everybody automatically gets a ballot like
California's system is slow, but we get like
everyone.
It depends on the county.
They're trying to get everyone to get a similar
model.
But yeah, generally speaking, especially if
you register ahead of time, it's mailed to
you have like 11 days to vote.
And if you're a last minute voter haze, you
still get to wait till the last day to decide.
And then you have you at least in L.A. this
specific year, you could bring it to any voting
center.
But most people didn't know that that was
the change.
So then there were still long lines.
But if everyone was on board with that kind
of system, you could just mail it or drop
it off somewhere and everyone would have theirs
at home.
So absolutely.
I don't know.
Maybe there's a way lately that I've always
really been warning people, if you are counting
on thinking of or expecting that the November
election will be delayed.
It's not going to be I can't think of any
way that that would really happen.
And remember, on the tail end of it, I don't
think that it shouldn't.
And if it didn't happen, eventually Nancy
Pelosi becomes president and there's no way
Trump would allow that to happen.
So the question is, can we get a system in
place that makes more sense where people can
vote remotely?
Unfortunately, I doubt that that's going to
happen.
And I think ultimately what this will be is
a battle of who how bad is the pandemic situation
at the time, who's willing to go out and who's
not?
And how do you value the risk of contracting
it versus your desire to cast a ballot in
November?
I think ultimately it's going to be as simple
as that.
And, you know, the new vote by mail systems
in states that don't have them postponements,
I don't think any of it's going to happen.
It's going to be who's actually going to say,
I want to vote enough that I will risk getting
the corona virus depending on how prevalent
it still is in November?
Do you think it's possible maybe just a couple
of states will change their laws beforehand,
maybe, maybe better, maybe they must.
I guess it just depends on the individual
state politics.
I'm guessing there's no real clear path on
the federal level to try to facilitate that.
There isn't.
And I think if states want to put it in place,
a system like that that don't already have
that system, if they don't start working on
that in the next four to six weeks, I think
it's just not going to happen because these
things take a very long time.
So depressing.
Thanks.
All right, appreciate the call.
Thank you